et pour parler de la stratégie du
développement de l'entreprise nous
sommes avec Laurent Rogel bonjour
bonjour enchanté
alors au vu de la du contexte actuel de
l'inflation comment évolue votre
activité comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
très fortement on est sur on est sur le
métier de l'offre de la rénovation
énergétique donc fabriquant historique
de pompe à chaleur
fabricant et développeurs de solutions
globales dans l'efficacité énergétique
donc on est sur une croissance d'environ
30 à 35% sur un marché qui croit déjà
lui d'une vingtaine de pour cent par an
et on arrive depuis déjà quelques années
à performer un petit peu plus que le
marché suite aux solutions innovantes
qu'on a pu développer depuis quelques
années on voit inflation réchauffement
climatique quelle solution vous proposez
face à ces problématiques là on est
clairement sur ces thèmes là on est sur
une volonté de partir du besoin du
client final de pas proposer les
solutions innovantes les plus innovantes
et les plus compliquées à installer qui
en deviennent des usines à SAV donc on
est vraiment dans l'approche solution
client final pour lui permettre
d'atteindre de manière réelle
l'efficacité énergétique donc on a des
solutions pour la pour la partie
résidentielle pour le marché des
particuliers et pour la partie tertiaire
pour le marché plus industriel autour du
marché de résidentiel et du particulier
on est sur une solution globale qui
intègre et une réponse à ses besoins de
chauffage de refroidit de
rafraîchissement d'eau chaude et un
apport en énergie via des panneaux
solaires photovoltaïques ou thermique et
aussi un apport en objet connecté en
data pour créer des scénarios
d'efficacité énergétique qui permettront
après de créer des algorithmes
apprenants d'efficacité énergétique donc
on est sur sur la volonté de proposer
une solution globale partant du principe
que l'efficacité ou la réduction des
consommations énergétiques ne pourront
venir que de l'ensemble que du système
que de l'écosystème n'est pas du produit
Pompe à Chaleur historique airwell voilà
qui est qui ne suffit pas à donner une
efficacité réelle c'est efficace sur un
banc d'essai mais si vous voulez pour le
particulier ça soit efficace il faut y
intégrer un apport en énergie de la data
et du contrôle pour que l'ensemble soit
efficace vous l'avez dit historiquement
c'est la pompe à chaleur comment c'est
fait la transition justement dans
l'évolution de la société pour aller
vers les autres solutions finalement pas
forcément ça parce que alors déjà nous
on est un fabricant historique de pompe
à chaleur le premier fabricant européen
de pompe à créant après la guerre 1947
donc il a fallu mener une véritable
mutation interne pour transformer ce
fabricant de produits en un développeur
fabricant créateur d'écosystèmes qui qui
parle aux clients final donc il a fallu
un intégrer des nouvelles expertises
qu'on avait pas forcément notre
expertise ou c'est le froid c'est la
terminologie c'était pas forcément
l'intelligence artificielle les objets
connectés c'était pas forcément le
solaire c'était même pas du tout le
solaire mais il a fallu voilà déjà
construire une véritable expertise R&D
ingénierie sur ce sur ces nouveaux
mondes
et puis après au niveau des forces
commerciales aussi c'est pas la même
chose de vendre un produit de vendre une
pompe à chaleur que de vendre un service
ou une solution donc de la formation
accompagner les accompagner nos
collaborateurs et notre réseau
d'installateurs de partenaires
distributeurs dans ces changements donc
on a dû pour cela même créer un centre
de formation et voilà académie pour
accompagner le changement de la filière
mais aussi en interne donc ça ça
nécessite beaucoup plus que simplement
rajouter une feuille dans un catalogue
c'est un vrai changement structurel
alors justement le gouvernement incite
aujourd'hui les entreprises à mettre en
place des plans sobriété énergétiques
auprès de leurs collaborateurs pour
participer à cette économie d'énergie
comment ça se passe chez vous qui êtes
pleinement engagé dans ce métier là tout
à fait alors c'est pas forcément le
cordonnier le mieux chaussé peut-être
mais parce qu'on essaie d'avoir un
niveau un petit peu en amont pour créer
quelque chose et être et s'engager sur
les résultats donc on a créé une offre
qu'on appelle easy une offre commerciale
avec des multiples partenaires qui
permet d'aller de l'audit énergétique à
un plan de recommolation et de sobriété
énergétique à la mise en place place de
ce de ce plan de recommandation par
l'installation des produits tout
financer sous forme de leasing
énergétique l'idée étant que le leasing
la mensualité de vos frais
d'investissement soit payés par
l'économie d'énergie générée par la mise
en place de ce système donc c'est assez
complexe il a fallu bien intégrer
plusieurs briques qui n'étaient pas les
nôtres donc on travaille Bureau Veritas
par exemple pour la partie audit on
travaille avec un partenaire pour la
partie borne de recharge de voiture on
travaille avec un autre partenaire pour
la partie éclairage parce que quand on
veut parler de rénovation globale il
faut avoir des expertise globale et on
ne peut pas tout faire on n'est pas
légitime à tout faire et on a donc à
travers à travers nos développements on
a voulu prouver l'efficacité réelle de
nos solutions donc le siège à 50 ans
d'Yvelines à Montigny
participera à partir de l'année
prochaine au championnat de France de
l'efficacité énergétique justement pour
en faire un bâtiment témoin et montrer
que nos solutions apportent de réel de
réels résultats
donc tout ça ça permet le fait de
participer à ce championnat de France
entre guillemets ça permet d'embarquer
aussi les équipes d'embarquer l'ensemble
de notre société d'abord dans des
changements de produits de conception
puis dans les changements
comportementaux comportementaux pardon
qui permettront après une amélioration
continue parce que c'est bien
d'atteindre un objectif de réduction
mais après il faut il y a toujours des
points à gagner sur le changement
comportemental alors avant d'aller
rejoindre Alexandre NT1 votre chef de
produit qui va nous expliquer justement
les différentes solutions rentrées dans
les détails techniques un dernier mot
parce que en septembre dernier votre
entreprise et côté a été introduit en
bourse
cotation Euronext
comment pourquoi en fait pourquoi quelle
est la stratégie derrière cette
introduction en Bourse l'objectif était
de financer cette croissance de financer
ce développement donc on a des réussites
mais on a besoin de partenaires
financeurs pour nous accompagner donc
les trois objectifs majeurs de cette
introduction en Bourse était de
récupérer du financement et pouvoir
faire des levées de fonds pour trois
objectifs principaux donc une croissance
externe donc les réussites qu'on peut
avoir en métropole l'objectif étant de
de le dupliquer aussi sur d'autres pays
on est présent dans 80 pays donc l'idée
étant de faire des acquisitions ou
renforcer notre présence dans certains
marchés internationaux la deuxième
partie était d'accélérer encore un petit
peu notre expertise notre montre en
compétence autour des métiers de la data
l'intelligence artificielle les objets
connectés donc de vraiment recruter et
construire une plateforme R&D dédiée à
cette offre-là et à cette expertise là
et la troisième partie était de se
renforcer aussi sur ce qui va devenir un
élément clé de nos développements à
savoir le service on doit offre service
ciel exige un niveau de qualité de
service optimum et pour cela on a
l'obligation de prendre un peu plus la
main sur la partie maintenance et
services donc on a aussi des projets de
croissance externe à ce niveau-là merci
Laurent Rogel c'est un plaisir merci à
vous rappelle que vous êtes le dirigeant
du groupe airwell et donc on va
rejoindre tout de suite Alexandre raté
qui nous expliquer justement les
solutions innovantes sur lesquelles vous
vous engagez actuellement